we talked
in today's
negotiations we talked about this single
defense
we
agreed that it's important to take
joint measures in order to ensure
security of the countries uh in the view
in the context of greater activity of
the nato
uh countries in the region and we
highlighted the success of the joint
military exercise of 2020
i'd like to also state that these
military exercises
military drills
[Music]
and i'm not a threat to any other
country
and they were planned and the all the
objectives of these drills have been
achieved
visited the trills
and he said that there were many
representatives from uh
defense ministries
were observed
and we talked
about the
contacts with western leaders
where we addressed uh the united states
and western leaders uh
with a view to to get guarantees of
security
[Music]
russian demands that were put forward to
the western leaders
where we are demanding
to return to the military potential of
the
nato block to the state of 1997
when
the founding act russia nato was signed
as i mentioned before
us and other
partners are not
accepting uh these uh demands or these
initiatives at the moment
we've also talked about certain ideas
that were transparent
ideas of transparency and limiting
certain types of weapons and we said
that russia is open to these
discussions and we said that they have
to be discussed these questions have to
be discussed in the context of other
russia's interests
we also talked about the
problems of
ukrainian conflict
the process of regulating
that crisis is
still being stolen
consultations with
norman uh
formats leaders
is not going forward
and
we see that there is sabotage
of the agreements and also the
amendments to the constitution to take
into account the eastern regions
and we see that also in ukraine there is
a
systematic violation of human rights and
discrimination for russian-speaking
populations
peace progress in ukraine is the
fulfillment of the minsk agreement
um
will also support
our further progress and tomorrow we
will also take part in the planned
events
uh that uh to continue our work on